Oh work today I know I just need a smoke
break tell me about it man
cigarettes I remember when I used to
smoke those yesterday um got this new
ecig I don't know how I feel about ecigs
you know I just think they're kind of
weird you like charge them in a computer
and just I just don't like it I mean if
I had to charge anything in the computer
it's probably be my new vape pen faves
yeah yeah no you can just like bring
these into any kind of food
establishment and just smoke inside the
great babes actually remind me of my
portable hookah I don't know that just
seems kind of inconvenient to me I just
carry this pretty much anywhere and
smoke it anywhere you know I've got this
thing that I've been in my family
actually for like 27 years or so looks
like a snorkel yeah I mean a little
trick do that and you know it's kind of
its kind of clean you probably haven't
seen this one before this is the hot box
it's really perfect
you bring that places like you're on a
date at the movies and you're just gonna
bring that in like the trunk of your car
yeah I mean if you wanna if you want a
good smoke sesh this is what you do do
you actually have a Steve yeah Steve
sorry we just kind of do this it's
really good he just filters out the
toxins and just takes a drag let's do
another one man
yeah it's really awesome that's nice but
have you ever tried smoking out of
yourself